pas céline voici romain goupil
allah
bonsoir est donc double peine à double
fait la porte à un personnage récurrent
de cette émission guy parce qu'il fait
partie des caries les quatre mecs qui
sont prononcés pour la guerre
effectivement avec lux man bruckner et à
la madeleine
ils sont quatre donc effectivement il
est souvent cette émission on est ravi
bonsoir romain goupil je me suis trouvé
dans des combats avec romain goupil
j'imagine oui qu'on se mette bien
d'accord ce soir je suis mais on va
essayer et
c'est la première fois que je passe à
cette émission
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
m'a prévenue effectivement j'ai vu une
cassette d'une d'une émission qui a eu
lieu ici le 22 mars avec un mec qui se
prénomme romain goupil cinéaste
c'est un sosie avant ce mec a insulté
des invités insultes et laurent baffie
tu as tenu tête en disant à quenza il
lui a postillonner en disant qu'elle
parlait de ne savait pas d'où elle
parlait qu'elle avait 14 ans que c'était
une petite conne qui traînait dans le
loft et qu'elle pouvait rien savoir
puisque le principe même but love s'est
on lit pas de journaux on regarde pas la
télé on regarde pas l'actualité
il a insulté il a insulté ma fille lui
répondant même pas aux questions il est
à traiter une horreur simon une chute
la chute c'est que c'est un sosie c'est
pas moi moi je suis sur les positions
sur les positions de thierry chaussures
tes positions jeu sur tes positions je
suis contre la guerre
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit on n'a pas
trouvé d'armes de destruction massive
donc on aurait dû continuer on aurait dû
absolument continuer à envoyer des
inspecteurs
on n'aurait rien trouvé il n'y a pas
d'argent massif se sont donc dit qu'est
ce qu'on aurait fait on aurait levé
l'embargo
on aurait permis à saddam de rester en
place d'avoir le prix du pétrole de
nommer son fils et son autre fils après
lui à 200% d'encore un vote extrêmement
démocratique et on aurait eu une
nouvelle corée du nord c'est à dire que
grosso modo l'erreur qu'on fait les
américains et les anglo-américains c'est
de virer saddam hussein par action là
dans l'europe non mais on a doublement
dans le cul parce que nous on lui a
vendu les arbres depuis 74
il ne les a pas réglé bon d'accord alors
maintenant bolfo beach et puis perles et
tous les américains nous disent vous
pouvez vous carrés dans le cul bodlet
bien placé pour faire la morale à tout
le monde donc on va perdre de l'argent
on perd les marchés puisqu'on n'a pas
participé de cet ingrédient choisi au
fait
moi je dit autre chose mon cher romain
la celle que c'est que c'est fait alors
les américains veulent tuer un chef
d'état comme ils l'ont fait avec
pinochet ou plutôt beau lapsus comme ils
l'ont fait avec parce que c'est un
dictateur qui m'a marqué et c'est
allende salvador allende qui a été tué
avec l'aide de la cia et du fbi
il faut être très bien avoir ces dames
100 100 assassiner les gosses et les
femmes et des vieillards
c'est ça
et
la dame hussein si vous voulez prendre
position chez vous un numéro à sa fiche
c'est un peu surprise de 40 la mine
c'est un peu surtaxé mais bon vous tapez
si vous êtes pour la guerre les deux si
vous êtes content c'est facile à l'abus
scène c'est
la guerre contre l'iran la guerre
contrôle koweit la façon dont il a
massacré son propre peuple
lui c'est une arme de destruction
massive lui donc c'est deux millions de
morts
les deux millions de morts tu me les met
en balance avec quoi avec un moment pour
libérer ce peuple effectivement faut
essayer seul avec le moine w on vous
délivre on nous la communauté
internationale nous mais bien de la
communauté internationale l'amérique a
fait la guerre tout seul avec
l'angleterre qui était le blaireau de
lamela lierse en la france et où la
lamelle a garé sur une coalition sans la
france et non c'est une ronde que la
manche n'est pas en angleterre en du
pays des droits de l'homme font ce que
bon lui semblait langis chopin en
espagne les trois qui ont soutenu vous
souhaites tu sais sur quel montant dans
la manifester en angleterre tu sais sur
quoi sur pr n'était fait pas la guerre
tu sais ce que ça veut dire ça prenait
le thé fait pas la guerre c'est à dire
tu m'intimides âge du lait dans ta coupe
de thé et tu regardes pas les massa qui
a eu ce tu regardes pas fameux voiture
garde pas les lieux du gazage des kurdes
réducteur rien c'est réducteur fou des
mines alors c'est réducteur les
manifestations qui a eu à paris avec le
portrait de saddam hussein c'est
réducteur la sagesse 2004 c'est la cdpa
page que je ne pouvais pas du tout et
n'importe quoi de la bourre pas d'aller
aux manifestations de jany le pen en
passant par vaillant en passant par la
droite et les humanistes donc j'ai pas
m'excuser de quoi que ce soit je me mets
à leur succès sur les positions de
chirac
c'est à dire non à la guerre et non à
cette guerre c'est à dire ses gains
alors ces guerres est illégal après elle
devient illégitime après c'est à dire
des forces d'occupation et après ça dit
un massacre c'est saïd mans dont il faut
demander à 20 h
il faut demander à un ramasseur alors
pour faire la fine bouche est ce que tu
vas laisser convoquer baird devant le
tribunal pénal international que boucher
galmi le chimique pour toi c'est ça
c'est exactement ce à quoi je veux faire
cette boue par région et par an
c'est un scandale chantal me dire quand
il ya eu au kosovo quand il ya eu au
kosovo et heureusement qu'on est
intervenue et on va se rendre compte
n'est pas passé par lille et insoumis
longtemps vachement bien je n'ai en 68
et dans un nuage ni jean bien à 80 ans
quand on est contre la guerre telle
qu'elle a été faite telle qu'elle a été
fait les canettes on est fatalement tout
que saddam hussein ça l'amusé
non j'aime pas ça c'est une parole
démocratique et voilà on sort on n'est
pas d'accord sur ce sujet là et donc on
se retrouve demain le subit zares je
comprends à bizarre que tu soutiennent
pas que tu comprennes pas qu'il y avait
un peuple irakien qui souffrait depuis
30 ans femmes 1
bah non plus même s'ils souffrent mois
souffrance l'usiné la preuve c'est
qu'ils font des manifestations c'est
imad le fassions des magiciens a vu les
pillages attisés par les jeunes
américains contre qui je n'ai rien les
malheureux sont là c'est des jeunes d'à
et on dit quand il ya eu des camps
justement on attaque les hôpitaux les
machins et que les que les médecins les
chirurgiens peuvent plus travailler etc
ils disent nous on n'a pas d'ordre on
n'a pas de consignes pour protéger sa et
et il protège également le pétrole là
qu'est partie partait pimpante par des
irakiens qui oui c'est à dire qu'un
armement 30 ans de système totalitaire
d'horreurs absolues 30 ans de dictature
et qu'est ce que ça a donné qu'est ce
que ça donnait une population
complètement acculturés qui va se manger
je mange et surtout les abeilles aux
gallois qui ne peuvent pas supporter des
dictatures jamais jamais les noms
parlent d'avant 89 avant la chute du mur
de berlin 10 ans et j'en suis je suis
tenté le ver le supporter les colonels
grecs qu'ils en supportent étalant ses
côtés ils ont supporté tous les
dictateurs de la planète pendant désert
blanc oui
comptez société la coexistence pacifique
avec des armes de destruction massive
des deux côtés il s'appuyait sur le camp
dit démocratique arrêt contre les
communistes et contre toute possibilité
que les communistes qu'elle du terrain
donc il sait des échanges je t'échange
le chili contre prague les autres
faisaient des horreurs à prague je
t'échange le chili je t'échange le
vietnam
contre quel telle dictature j'étais
change cuba contre tête c'était une
période redémarre désolé des rues entre
je veux descendre de l ont pas pour rien
non ces déséquilibres de la terreur tu
leur parles dans 50 ans tête reposée
thierry et laurent soit pas d'accord
mais que toi
écoute le j'essaye de diniz est plate où
tu as raison c'est diviser pour régner
les gens demandent si une cassette des
bas pour gagner bien sûr mais pour
rendre compte de l'horreur
ce que je voudrais pas moi ce que je
voudrais pas laurent et thierry c'est
voir ça hirai la dernière forme chirac
sont georges d'un cap
oui je voudrais pas voir effectivement
ça ne serait désagréable par rapport à
la façon dont vous vous êtes engagé sans
arrêt dans cette émission laurent et
thierry en change de cap maintenant
chirac dit et villepin c'est là qu'on
sig puis de principe pragmatisme on va
essayer de faire en sorte que la
libération du peuple irakien se passe au
mieux ce à dire
l'humanitaire remettre de l'eau j'ai
bien fait on allait très bien de celui
fait chier parce que les mecs ça fait
trois semaines qu'ils ont rien à boire
mais ils boivent l'eau des lots boisés
j'aidais mon dieu ça va s'entendre mais
papa tendance aux américains qui sont
capables de la langueur avant huit jours
on doit bien être capables de leurs murs
d'aujourd'hui tant déçu jamais tu
préféré la stabilité quand il y avait sa
dame quand il y avait lectrices it et
qui marchait pour torturer les mecs
quand il y à vélo dans les baignoires
pour les emporter qu'on pouvait
transporter la cie tranquillement et
dissoudre les corps c'est ça que je
voulais non ce qu'on a c'est ce que l'on
chérit les bombes américaines sur la
gueule dans les faubourgs de bugs ne
baissions roland baron alors bien il ya
eu dans toute la presse là là alors les
jours que la la la couverture partisane
dans le papier du moins tous les
journaux vous dites que la presse
française un mini moules et lower la
tyrannie bassiste oui enlisement c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné il essaye
d'aller sur bagdad pour chauffer ce
qu'ils appelaient décapité assassiné
saddam hussein et essayer de décapiter
les dirigeants qui sont une horreur une
camarilla une garde prétorienne but on
est d'accord on est la coordination cei
le premier joue de la défense
on ne sait pas en tout cas en tout cas
ça continue et là dessus qu'est ce que
fait la presse et qu'est ce que font les
journaux ils disent enlisement pourquoi
parce que les anglo américains ont
essayé de contourner les villes ne pas
faire tapis de bompas tapis de bombes
comment 91 45 jours de préparation
d'artillerie par les avions
pas tapis de bombes comme en service 72
jours de bombardements aériens avant de
mettre un pied par terre ils sont ils
ont fait ils ont lancé une bombe et le
lendemain ils ont avancé en contournant
les villes en risquant de se faire
couper par les arrières et là tout le
monde avec un petit sourire en disant ah
[ __ ] ils vont pas y arriver ils vont
s'enliser et les photos dans tous les
journaux
c'était le bourbier c'était le vietnam
tout le monde un sms de jouissance
incroyable mais même tu connais le
suaire le saint suaire de turin et balla
sur les pages du figaro
quand il y avait des experts militaires
qui s'exprimait où les experts
soviétiques ont former l'armée irakienne
mais on voyait des traces de sperme
tellement il jouissait en disant ils
vont se planter
ils vont se casser la gueule ils vont
pas y arriver arrivé à quoi à libérer le
peuple irakien mais tu sais ce que ça
veut dire le moulin guérillaé le peuple
irakien jeudi a qu'une envie tout ce
qu'on les turbans là bas ils n'ont
qu'une envie c'est les virer les rires
et après l'amour absolu partiellement
soir le parlait parlait par le peuple
kurde plus assez d'eau que depuis dix
ans e
grâce à l'excès à ce qu on appelle les
zones d'exclusion aérienne immigrent la
démocratie et quand les américains sont
arrivés c'est eux qui les ont sauvés des
gens 88 pensent que les chutes ils ont
envie dans le sud du pays de voir
arriver les américains à baker présent
j'ai vu des mecs avec des turbans
clement c'est vous le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est ce qu'on a vu à la télé et ce
qui transparaît ses robes pas des
américains en veut pas de forces
d'occupation et nous on veut l'islam est
ce que c'est le laisse comme l'iran
l'irak maintenant le sud de l'irak
ben comme l'iran ce qu'ils on essaye de
faire comme de 60% de chiites en irak et
ben écoute et la démocratie c'est les
schistes au pouvoir et ce qu'essayent
ces cellules - là c'est ce qu'essaye de
faire les mollahs le peuple irakien qui
n'est pas tous sous la coupe des mollahs
et et leur donner des moyens comme au
kosovo
exactement comme au kosovo de s'exprimer
ne ré apprendre à faire des journaux de
réapprendre à faire des des émissions de
télé à discuter mais à s'engueuler
éventuellement à pas être torturé ou tué
si on a dit quelque chose
montre quelqu'un à un moment donné de
réapprendre la démocratie en étant
dangereux et n'a pas envie d'aller avec
une caméra
par exemple en irak si j'ai envie de
rester ici de discuter avec toi discuter
avec tous les rêves
en vérité avec le c'est normal dit comme
ils sont quatre à défendre les
américains toujours du boulot des mecs à
temps chargé avant de clubber temps
complet j'ai plutôt du côté des mineurs
il s'est donc très beau je suis pas du
tout convaincu
non pas du tout c'est pas parce que je
me tais qui est qu'il a raison non mais
il dit par exemple le romain enfin il
dit avec bruce nauman dans le monde que
l'anti-américanisme c'est nationalisme
des imbéciles non mais c'est ce qu'on
veut ce qui est dit par là c'est que ce
que vous avez fait au tout début
d'émission
bush est un imbécile alors chirac ait pu
le grand con le grand menteur le facho
les eaux est toujours su qu'ils étaient
dénoncés donc ma tante derrière
incroyable qu'est gaullien qu'à une
position bolliet la wii sur le coup des
positions mondiales prospectiviste non
vers ce linge est arrivé là ce qui se
passe
la façon dont ils ont démissionné par
rapport je vis à vis du chien dit
reviens guy tu vois je voulais passer en
guise
elle va lui
volent bien entendu il va taper tirons
bien me rends bien oui j'en passe alors
on n'est pas fâchés ils adorent discuter
la douleur sauf que là le problème est
compliqué il ya eu une telle
désinformation en france en dix ans on
était dans le camp de la paix alors
qu'on ait fait on n'était pas dans le
camp de la paix on était dans le camp de
la honte de la collaboration avec saddam
hussein avec un as à 100 avec un tueur
avec un tueur de son peuple
mais enfin quand même quelques la
capture de millions de personnes mais
vous savez ce que ça veut dire évoluer a
eu un comme ça il ya dix ans doit fêter
bas parce qu'ils sont jeunes de la
expliqué le compte la réalité quand
quand saddam hussein s'est battu contre
l'iran tout le monde était bien content
qu'il arrête là l'islamisme exacte et la
guerre iran irak c'était 14 18 ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça on peut pas lui
reprocher la guerre contre l'iran
bijouterie - étaient ravis qu'il a fallu
après la façon dont il a traité assure
simon et même je vais vous dire pire
c'est à dire que la france en 75
balleux 2t saddam hussein car les
deuxièmes réserves de pétrole au monde
va le doter d'une industrie nucléaire
mais tout le monde est bidonné tous les
services de renseignement sont bidonnés
en 10 ans commence à la france fournit
un réacteur nucléaire
asada y reviendrons bien combien
bien savoir c'est un jeu de rôle
moi j'ai un petit j'ai regardé en plus
il va membres at his ampleur pour vous
l'impression que cette guerre elle va
encore d un sacré bout de temps
oui alors si terry pour toi te faire
traiter de pétainiste quand même parce
que c'est ce qui va dire j'aime bien en
main goupil mais je m'en fous de ce
qu'il dit de faire ces films n'ont
jamais dit que j étais pétainiste jeudi
la position de chirac était une position
pas du tout goal com l'avenue de
beaulieu
moi je reste un homme libre libre de nos
mots d'ordre livres et quand je pense
quelque chose fût ce avec le pen jouer
j'aime le vin rouge je crois que le pen
aime le vin rouge si il fait caca tous
les jours et mois pas autant que je
voudrais pas le problème on fout je n'ai
jamais pensé à le pen dit jamais pensé
et même à la limite tu si je pense à
girac
moi j'essaye de j'essaye d'être fidèle à
moi-même et d'une certaine manière c'est
donc très à la fois caricatural est
assez pervers de vouloir dire que quand
on est contre cette guerre on soutient
un dictateur comme saddam hussein
ça se pourrait nous révolter me mettre
en colère parce que c'est pas vrai c'est
partout comme moi c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai du tout je serai comme fou si
je devenais ça mais mais mais mais où
elle a le succès effectivement ils vont
donner le pouvoir à des intégristes à
des gens qui vont ça va être les fous
d'allah qui vont prendre le pouvoir
comme en iran je suis désolé je suis
d'accord avec eux l'addition de ces
deux-là conséquent
et et puis ils ont pas trouvées et
saddam hussein il s'est envolé il
passait son temps à tirer les oui mais
il a garé sa voiture devant les moyens
parce que dans le dans le système
pétrole contre nourriture le fameux
embargo quand on voit ces palais quand
on voit ces robinetterie en or
effectivement il doit être en thalasso
quelque part j'espère que non mais
sûrement sur laquelle il s'occupe des
arrière-pensées pétrolière dans cette
guerre que c'était simplement une bière
de libération tu n'es pas effleuré par
un tout petit doute quand on connaît le
palmarès de l'indochine et de ckoi je
préfère je préfère que le pétrole soit
aux mains de la coalition des anglais
des allemands des espagnols et tout
plutôt que de saddam hussein et le pam
huracan de l'arabie saoudite et qu'elle
soit le peuple irakien qu'en profitent
effectivement je prédis avec les
américains histoire son fils thomas d'al
hussein qui va profiter du psg assure
bien sûr comme ça au kosovo mais gagner
on a le dernier mot chacun sa vérité
comme disait pirandello
la péter
george bush votre ami romain goupil
prépare à voir lui comme ami que ça
l'amusé ce bal autres amis c'est la
mission non plus au revoir aux mains à
lens plus grosses sommes
et
ça
je poussais
de sanaa
et maintenant